ご質問などある方は挙手いただければ
はい どうぞ  あのエラーチェックなんですけれども
今あの会社の方っていうのはですね
あの 雪印に始まって 私も飲食関係のシステムですけれども
今回もまた不二家にも出まして
あの他の三菱の自動車のリコールの問題もそうですけれども
もう社会全体がですね
まあ大企業問わず中小企業においてもですね
もうあの会社の名目としては合理化とか
要するに効率化のためと言ってますけれども
すべてがですね 儲け主義で利益至上主義でですね
全部そのシステムがその方向で構築されていって
その流れの中で 要するに道徳感を持って
また周りの人間のことも思ってですね
考えると 自分のエラーをチェックするの中でですね
どうしてもこの自分の倫理観から外れた中で仕事をに流されているという
今状況なんですけれども
やっぱりあの 先ほどの話にもあった通りにですね
果物の中でですね 一つでも腐っているものがあれば
それはもう全体に波及していくんだということでですね
あの  本当にこの道徳感に欠けるようなシステムが導入されたされているということに気づいた時はですね
自分としてはやっぱりそれに対してちゃんとした
その自分なりの倫理観を持ったチェックをした中でですね
会社の方にやっぱりちゃんと意見はしていくべきなのか
それとも大きな事故にはつながらないだろうという考えのもとで
まあそのままでやっていっていいのかというところをちょっとお聞きしたいと
思います 微妙ですけど
あの言ってもいいと言っちゃうとね
まあ人の他人の過ちっていうのは簡単に見えますからね
言い出しちゃうとどこまで言うかっていうこともあります
一般的な落ち着いた仏教の世界では
まあ人のことではなくてね
自分が間違いを起こさないようにと自分の修行として生きるのは普通な仏教的な生き方なんです
これ 普通とちょこっと変わって言うべきかという場合は
言うならば大胆に言わなくちゃいけないんです
聞かせてやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
これでもいいんじゃないかなという言い方では
誰も聞いてくれません
みんな俺が正しいということで言うんだからね
あ これが大変だ 大騒ぎされてるんだ
なんか問題が起きて どうしようかということのように
相手聞いている側が困ったなという気持ちにさせない限りは
言ってることは聞いてくれませんよ
だから言うならば大胆に言うしかないんです
私にも随分優しく あのもう生ぬるく喋れますよ
喋れません そういうふうに大胆に言うんです
とにかく聞かせてやるという
ですから あの見える間違いっていうのは
もう大胆に言うか あるいはそうでないと
まあ自分が失敗しないように
やるしかないんです うーん
だから社会システムはね
まあこういう数字だけで利益だけで生きる人間はどうでもいいという
このへりくつはね 人間が言って食品買って食べてるでしょうに
人間が言って車買って使ってるでしょうに
あなた方とは関係ないんだというこの態度
いくら技術を持ってる三菱やと言ったっても
そんな態度だったらね
もう買う必要ないということになるんです
それからちょこっとした見えん張ってね
巨大な会社だから ものすごい技術を持ってる会社だから
こんな欠陥なんかあると言っちゃうとまあ恥ずかしいと思ったでしょうね
それごまかしてお客様のせいにしようとしたところで
どれぐらいあのバカどもたちが損したかと
それから車が売れなくなっちゃって
まあ普通の乗用車を作ってる会社でもないんだからね
ものすごい大きなものを作ってるでしょうに
で これをした損どれぐらいかと
まあ不二家やらそういう会社も潰れちゃったんだから
長い歴史の会社が まあなんとかして名前残りましたけど
でももう今惨めでしょ
他の誰かの会社と一緒にもう合体しましたから
だから誰かの体に寄生して生き続けなくちゃいけないって
その惨めは何なのかと
寄生的に生きることはすごい惨めでしょうに
だから それでも人間っていうのは利益ばっかり考えるという
だからその愚かさっていうのは相当なもんで
我々個人には直せるものじゃないんですよ
だから因果法則を信じて
悪行為は悪行為をする人に結果が来る
まず我々も一応繋がって不幸になりますけど
まあ一人一人が正しく生きることが一番早道なんですよ
だから法則は逆も同じですよ
だから周りが全部悪くなっちゃうと自分も悪くなっちゃうし
しかし 一人の人でもしっかり真面目に仕事をして道徳を守って
いわゆる間違いはしないで仕事をすることが善行為であると
慈しみの行為であると理解してやると
その人の周りにいる人々だけでも穏やかになって
じゃあ私たちもやっぱり真面目にやろうよという気分になりますよ
それが広がる可能性もあります
だからわざわざと何とか行動を引き起こさなくても
そういうふうに地道に行動で広げるという方がしっかりはしています
言うべきかないかということはかなり複雑ですよ
言っただけでは聞いてくれないし
まあ裁判にもみんな一生懸命言ってるでしょうに
聞いてくるんだから 裁判官さえも
政治家もね まるっきり能力はなくてね
ちょこっとした法律変えることもできないし
かできる能力はあるんだ
やりませんね 例えば暖炉と天下りの問題っていうのは
よくよく考えるんだ 考えるんだと言いながら
これやりたくないんだからなんですよ
だからもっとするがすごく暖炉と天下りできるようにとシステムを作るんです
もっとバレない方法ないのか
もっとバレない方法ないのかと
だから そんなだからなんか頭が悪そうに見えるんですよ
本当は悪くないんです
だから悪いことに使うんだから悪くはなっちゃうんですね
だから話は言っても聞いてくれません
一般国民が何言ったっても
政府は聞きません 政府いうことは国民が聞かなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから政府がいろいろ手を動かして自分の意見が通るようにする
会社は社長たちが その管理の人々は自分のもうみんなもう世界知らないし
もう閉じ込められた部屋の中に生活するし
自分が夢見るような感じのことはもう社員にもうやらせるでしょうしね
現場で仕事をしている人々の話は聞かない
そこであまり詳しく見ていないんですけど
ほんの 2 3 分だけ長い番組をちょこっと見たんですよ
あるなんかお年の方ですか
なんか何か別な会社作って
みんな老人なんですね
会社の社員たちは老人
例えば 60歳以上で で
確実に年功序列やと で
特別にいい仕事をしたんだからって
それはあんまり気にしないと
うん いわゆるノルマが絶対ないと
病気だったら休めと で
そういうことで仕事をやって
なんか品物をいろいろお客さんにいろいろ送ったりする会社みたいし
それで 1年に一回会社のみんな休んでどこかに遊びに行くみたいです
2 3週間とか 1ヶ月半とか
会社まるまる休みで それで負担は会社が取ると 1億分かかるみたい
それでまあかかったということで
それでその 1ヶ月間どうしようかというと
このお客さんに対しては
各仕事をしている会社に
自分の倉庫の合鍵を何千枚も作って一つ一つ配ってるみたい
その間は会社やってないんだから
自分たちの品物は持っていってくださいと
しかし 見事にうまくいってるんだ
その会社は 誰をインタビューしても
みんなものすごく喜んで
もうある女性がね 自分がなんか旦那の病気か誰かの病気ですごく困ってる時は
まあ堂々と行ってセールやってくださいと休ませてくれたんだと
そんなありがたいことはないんだと
だから一つの会社でもなんか人間第一やというね
まず人間やということでやっていて
それで NHK の番組でしたけど
そちらの経営者がいたんですけどね
あんた方どう思います？と言ったら
そちらの反応は ああ あれはしっかりした商売でうまくいってるんだから
そういうことできているんだよとかね
どう何言ってるのかと
あのシステムだから仕事うまくいってるのに
だから一人一人がすごい真剣に仕事をしてる
喜んで喜んで それが仕事をうまくいってるんだから
ああいう方法をやっているんだと
こっちは勘違いする 一人の若い人
若手なんですけど うちの会社もそういうのやりたいんだから
あんた方もしっかり頑張りなさいよとテレビ向けて自分の社員に言うんです
それだったらものすごく気持ち悪い会社でしょうね
だから社員たちがものすごく牛みたいに苦労して
馬みたいに苦労して 頑張って儲けてあげるならば
そこそこと新鮮にしてやるぞという
だからテレビで出た会社がそうじゃなくて逆なんです
60歳の人を雇う 仕事をできるならば
あれがなんとかないんですね
なんて言いますか あの定年というのはなし
な 病気になったらどうぞ休んでくださいと
ノルマはつけません それでみんないきなり元気になっちゃうんですよ
やる気が出てくるんでしょうに
だから体を動かさずにいられなくなっちゃいますから
ノルマがないんだから
ストレスも何ともないし
だからできた仕事で本人が喜んじゃうしね
これぐらいできたわ 今日はとかね
そういうことで この今日はそのことは突然見ただけで
それも番組見てないんです
ちょこちょこと次のチャンネル変える間の時間でしたからね
まあ 2 3分だと思いますけど
そういう会社もあることは一つぐらいだけでもありますよ
だから我々はそうじゃなくて
世界はね みんなもう恐ろしい利益主義で
人間が死んでも儲かるべきであると
例えば戦争産業っていうのは明らかにそれでしょう
人を殺して儲かる産業だから
だから個人はどうしますかね
個人は今日言ったような感じで
自分の心をチェックして
自分が間違いをしないで生きていればいいんです
会社倒産しちゃっても
自分が悪いことしてないんだから
自分は不幸にならないとは思います
難しいポイントですけどね
まあ言うべきかっていう問題ですから
やっぱり言う場合はやっぱりそれぐらいの声がないと言っても無駄し
逆に自分がもうもう悪く扱いされる可能性もあります
言うならば もう聞こえるぐらい大きい声で言わなくちゃいけないんです
わかりました  はい  今の例で
三菱自動車と野村縫布と
それからクリアの例が出たんですが
私の記憶では三菱自動車の場合と野村の場合には
実際に被害者が出たんですね
被害者というか 会社の経営
あの 何て言うんですか
チェックが甘かったために事故が起きたり
あるいは牛乳を飲んでお腹を壊した人が出たわけですが
クリアの場合はですね
確か消費期限を切れた材料を使ったと
ただ 実際にそれによってお腹を壊した出たわけではなくて
あるいは確か 内部告発だと思うんですけども
今言ったその会社が何か問題エラーチェックをする時に内部告発をするという行為についてはですね
最近の話題のこの人本とか何か読みましたですが
他人の悪い点をですね
まあ何て言うんですかね
暴露するというようなことをよくないんじゃないかと
というふうなことをおっしゃってられたりもするんですけども
内部告発というのはどう法的からどう考えたらいいんでしょうか
正々堂々と言うべきなんでしょうか
それとも やはり人間弱いものですから
エラーを見つけて自分が守って
それを指摘するのは怖いので
自分を隠してその信用者を動かさせるとか
そういうことをする人もいるわけですけれども
そういうのは一般論ではちょっと語りにくいところでしょうね
やっぱり 例えば会社がわがままで
もう社員のことをあんまり親切に扱ってないとかね
あんた方はただの社員で歯車だよという調子でいると
まあ会社に対しては愛情が生まれてこないしね
喋っても聞いてくれないし
そうなってくると どこかで社員たちがこれはもう会社を崩す
崩しちゃうっていうのは当然な結果でしょうしね
うーん まあ人類に迷惑をかけているんだと
もう隠れてもう大変なことをやっているんだと
これは国にとっては 国民にとっては良くないんだと
会社は私のことはすごい心配してはいるんだけど
しかしやっていることはもう大きいスケールで見ると良くないという気持ちで
まあこの場合はやっぱり告白
秘密で告白するしかないというふうなケースもあり得るしね
社長と怒ってるわけじゃないんですけど
もう社長って何か言える立場じゃないしね
というか   内部告発だけれども
実際ですね 全社的に違法行為をやってたわけですからね
うんうん それとはやっぱりその従業員のですね
管理ももうずさんだったんですよね
うんうん だからひどいサービス残業もありましたしね
はいはい だから まあそれはやっぱり勇気のある人の告発だったと思うんですけど
そうそう だから内部告発される状態になったっていうことでもう失敗だからね
会社はね だから森永のケースでは
森永じゃなくて不二家のケースではね
まあちょこちょこと賞味期限切れたものを扱ったならば
そんな大きな問題じゃないんですよ
もう食べ物っていうのは
賞味期限切れて切れて 1 秒で悪くなるわけじゃなくて
あと何日でも持てるし
まあ私は飲む牛乳なんかはね
結構賞味期限は切れてますけど
一度もお腹壊したことはないし
しかし 法律的にはまあそういうものは安全のために決めてるんだから
やっぱり他のところでいろいろ崩れていったと思いますよ
うん だからまあ そういうところでまあ知られてしまったっていうね
今回 うちのグループ会社なんですけれども
新小岩の蕎麦屋でですね
カレーの鍋にですね ネズミが入ってた
それを 18食くらい出したんですかね
それも要するにパートのおばちゃんが正直にこんなのが入ってましたということで
会社の方でプレスリリースをですね
やったんですけれども
そこもやっぱりかなり社員さんを置かないで
要するに人件費を削るために
パートのおばちゃんにもう要するにきつい仕事をつけてたんですよね
だからネズミが入ったのがわからなかったのは大変だったと思います
うん うん 今だからいろんな場所でですね
要するにその適正な人数がいないとか
要するに無理な労働をさせるとかということでですね
衛生的に結構 あの  食べ物の場合は衛生的に
他のところはもうなんか
この この小泉さんの新しいシステムが出た途端
いろんなところでものすごい大事件が起きたでしょ
あの火事があったり あの鉄柱会社って生成会社
そのままね あれも人件面白く削減しちゃって
経験者が亡くなったっていうね
損は並みじゃないんですよ
人間 3人を減らしただけで
それで大事故起きちゃって
その損はいくらでしょうかとね
やっぱり人間を大事にするべきなんですよ
いくらなんでも 日本は今までいくらなんでも
やっぱりまあ一旦会社に入ったら
人のことを大事にしましたからね
もう最近ほど問題も起きなかったでしょ
で 全部この新しいアメリカのシステムにしたんだから問題になったし
アメリカが日本のシステムを学んでいますけどね
面白いことに  JR もそうなんですよ
うん あの 要するにそのコンピューター化ですか
システム化を もう最新の技術をですね
アメリカなんかと提携して
向こうのコンピューター会社から新しいシステムを入れるんですよ
そうすると技術者が間に合っていかないんですよね
だから今まで考えられなかったその信号故障でですね
山手線が 1時間半止まるとかですね
そういうのも そういった
要するにその会社側の
要するに効率化 合理化というのがですね
要するに人と技術者とのミスマッチを起こしているということですね
それも本当は私から見れば
あれは失敗なくすエラーチェックじゃないんですよ
世界的に情報を見ると
みんな日本のこの電車システムに対しては驚くばっかしで
あれってありえないんだよと
どうやってあの人々はね
こんな秒単位で精密に全国で電車を動かしているのかと
これは蜘蛛の巣のようにものすごいでしょうね
どこでも遅刻なくぴったし動いちゃって
遅刻したっても もうたまたまラッシュで
もうちょこちょこと 5分ぐらいで
あるいはもう雪が大雪で
地震でなんとかなんであってね
こんなにも世界で誰でも驚く腰が抜けるシステムがあるにも関わらず
全く電車全然使ってないアメリカのシステムを買うということは
どういう意味ですかね
アメリカで電車がない
あることはあるんだけど
あれは長距離だけだけでね
あれは別なことでしょ
別ななんとかで高い何億円のお金でしょ
そんなものは それでかなりリベートもあるし
そういうすごい悪行為だと思いますよ
でないと日本から行ってアメリカに教えた方がいいのに
ヨーロッパでは電車システムはよくできてますけど
それでも日本のシステムほど精密にしっかりということはないし
だから現場の人間と全然すり合わせない
そうそうそう  要するに
会社側が一方的に契約で新しいシステムを入れるんで
それでかなりその設備の人とかですね
運転手の人もかなり苦労している
だからあの痛みのね 事件もものすごく苦労させてるってね
まあそれまたすぐに隠蔽
隠蔽したりもするし まあ全体的に
まあそれは特別に日本のあの会社
この会社っていうのは失礼なんですけど
全体的に世界はそうやって人間の命を尊重しないで
金だけね 儲かることだけを考えているんだから
まあ結果としては赤字ですからね
それでも気づかないということも本当に面白いんですけどね
原発事故の場合はね すごい損でしょうに
だからちゃんと管理すればいいでしょうに
それはもう高慢で見栄で管理しない
ちょっとでも事故を起こしちゃったら
もう想像できないでしょうに
だから慈しみがないんですよ
あちらこちら原発はあってもいいんですよ
みんな慈しみがあるならば
これとんでもない品物を代物を扱っているんだよというね
人間を守らなくちゃいけないという気持ちが出てくるでしょうに
だからいちいちチェックする場合は楽しいんですよ
これ 人間を守るためにOK
これはOK これはOKとかね
だから人間の命を守るためにやっているんだよということはもう消えちゃうんですね
そうなってくると エラーチェックというのは本当にすごい楽しいことになるんですよ
隠すことまでするんだから
もう話にならない まあこれはね
もう現代社会っていうのはね
まあ我々東洋的な生き方じゃないんだからね
やっぱり初めからもう物は優先というね
命は後から来たんだよという
哲学ですから であって
西洋の人々にいまだに倫理道徳は語らないでしょうに
ハチャメチャでね 学校でも倫理は教えるけど
ハチャメチャなんだよ
教えているものは あれ
いかにして西洋の倫理の間違いは
いかにして現状を正当化するのかと
これは日本の学校で教えている倫理の授業とか NHK
を通してちょこちょこっと見たことはありますけど
すごい金をかかっていろんな道徳問題子どもたちに投げるんですよ
例えば猿を捕まることとかね
ビデオを撮ったりして
猿が民家に入ってものすごい迷惑をかけることを撮ったりして
それからもう猿を捕まったりする
時々熊を殺したりもする
で  2回もこの熊がここ 1回放してあげたところでまた来たんだよと
ですからもう人間に慣れきっているんだから
で 危険だからといって殺すとかね
そういうものを子供に見せて
はい 道徳的な どういうこと？どういうことで話し合いなさいと
子供は知るわけないでしょうに
いきなりそんなこと聞いたっていうのは
だからそれを教えることじゃないでしょうね
子供は自分の意見はなんだらかんだら言うでしょうね
ああそうですか ああ そういう考え方もある
ああ そういう考え方もある
それが道徳の授業なんです
結局 だから子供たちは猿が悪くはないんだとか
いや やっぱり人間の方が大事じゃない
もう一人の子供はやっぱり人間の方が大事じゃないんでしょうかとかね
猿を守るために人間を殺すべきか
私は考えますから 猿を殺すべきやという
もう一人の子 いえ それは良くないんだよと
やっぱりみんな仲良くしなくちゃいけないんだよとか言う子供もいて
それでじゃあどうするのかと
答えないでしょうね 子供たちには
先生も知らないし だからなんでこの能力ない人でなきゃ仕事を頼まないという
あ 今日道徳の授業がありますけど
道徳はまるっきり知らない先生いないのかと
言うと 道徳はまるっきり知らない先生
あ あなた教えてくださいという
笑 だからもう例えばもう喋れない人に音楽授業やらせるような感じですよ
歌を声楽を学んでいる授業を学ぶ学生さんたちはいますけど
誰かろうあろう 何でしたっけ？喋れない人はろうあろうわの人がいないのかと
それでその人が来て授業を喋る
歌い方を教えるとかね
そんなやり方なんですよ
もう本当に だから 特に道徳の場合は
この現状をなんとか認めてくれと
どうしようもなくこうなってるんだよと
他やり方法やり方ないでしょというメッセージなんですよ
これやるなよっていうことはないんです
だからいじめの問題でも
まあいじめるいじめる側もまあしょうがないんですね
いじめられる やっぱりそれもしょうがないんですね
そんな断定的に犯人扱いしてはいけません
あ そうか じゃあ現状維持かという
いつでも現状維持 現状維持っていうのは
この発展しないという意味でしょ
だから崩れるに決まってますよ
見る見る限り 家庭は崩れるは
会社は崩れるは 世界システムがもうずっと崩れて崩れていくんです
まあ一応まあそんなところだと思いますけど
私は まあ西洋の方にも
自分が悪いことをして
戦争して 人の財産を奪って奪って
どんどんどんどんどんどん豊かになって
すごく物のありあふれた国を
国々 社会を作って それからそれは正しいと言わなくちゃいけない
だから一生懸命正しい
人殺すのは正しい だって正義
悪人を殺さなくちゃいかないんだと
あんた殺したのは悪人でしょうかと聞きたいんだけど
なんでアメリカの原住民たちを殺したんですかね
殺して殺す それから我々は善人だから
この原住民の人々を守らなくちゃいけないと
あるどこかの地方に どこにも何も生活も何もできない
どこかに放り込んじゃって
そこで終わり それっていうのは
そのまま残酷な違法行為でしょうに
非道徳でしょうに アメリカで堂々と生きていた人々でしょうに
エスキモーの人々も同じことよ
どこかに放り込んじゃって
全部必要なものをあげて
はい こちらへ住んでくださいと
それが道徳講義であって
古い文化を守るんだよと
原住民を守るんだよと
また偉そうなことを言う
アフリカ オーストラリアでもそうでしょうに
人の財産を奪ってから
じゃあアボリジニを守ってやりましょうとか
こんなことを我々やっていますよと
アボリジニの文化祭をやってますよ
今年はとか だからみんないかに残酷に非道徳的な生き方をしているかというのを気づきもしないし
現状を正当化するという哲学なんです
このヨーロッパの哲学者も
道徳や倫理からモラリティ
エティクスと喋っているときと同じなんです
いかにして現状を維持できるのかと
だからこの仏教みたいに
この断定的に成長 成長
成長 止まるなよ 止まれませんよと
止まらないものは止め合う
止めようとしちゃうと
そこで破壊終わり 崩れます
だからもう変化して変化して
もう生きなさいよという生き方じゃないんだからね
だから仏教はいつでもこうしなさい
これをやめなさいとはっきりするんです
それから微妙にちゃんと整理して
道徳はきちんと立証しているはずなんです
仏教学者にはなかなか大変できません
仏教学者 そんなにね 頭いいわけじゃないんだから
あの英語で書いている仏教の論文の中でも
今日の程度のものもないんですよ
皆さんはすごい あまり価値がない
もうまあまあ 私は手抜きしていると思ってるかもしれませんだけど
この内容はないんです
英語で書いてるところにしたっても
ですから 日本語でないのは当たり前で
英語の方が研究先ですからね
もう誰も だから今日のポイントはたった一つ
エラーチェックは 倫理ですよと
だから経済 損得だったら経済
儲かるかないかって言ったら
それは経済学に入ります
倫理は経済学じゃないんです
命を価値にすることです
まあまあ そういうことで複雑です
まあはい ...失敗を認めるっていうのが
認めているつもりですぐ後悔する
落ち込むっていう方に入ってしまうんですけれども
そう もしそうだとしたら
失敗を認めようなんて考えるよりも
もうやっぱりその次のことに
とにかくチェックでエラーチェックを入れる中で挑戦するっていうのしかないのかなっていうふうに
とにかく認めて また後悔したりするということは
吾輩は完璧やということですよ
だから精神的にぶつかるんですよ
それがなかったら失敗認めたって何のこともケロッといられますよ
例えば子供たちは一番小さい
すごい可愛いのはそういうわけや
子供たちは小さい時は大人と一緒にいるんだから
子供の時だけ性格はいいんですよ
それで子供は比較してみると
大人にはいろんなことを上手にできちゃって
自分もやりたくてやりたくてたまらないんですけど
それでいろいろやってみたりするんですけど
明らかに失敗する それであらら
失敗したねって言ったら
ケロッとにこっと笑ってるんです
泣いたりはしません 失敗しているのに
子供は知ってますよ これは失敗やと
でもそこでは後悔したり落ち込んだり
またもう二度と挑戦しませんって
これ全然ありえない またやるんです
だからその場合は大人と一緒にいるんだから
子供がその時点で吾輩は完璧やっていうとこはないんです
だから失敗したっても明るいし
誰も怒らないし もうなんとか直す
問題は解決してあげる
我々は自分の失敗は認めても
やっぱり後悔する羽目になると
気持ち悪くなるというならば
もう吾輩は完璧やというすごい邪見があるということで
だからよく理解して ものは不完全であると
仕事っていうのは自分と他人との関係で
自分が肉体が持ってて心を持ってる
両方生物 相手も物質か生物かどちらかと
その関わりだから 一つももう先に読めません
だからもう失敗っていうのは確率ははるかに高いと
成功したらこれすごい珍しい
当たったぞという感じなんですよ
当たったそうだから なんで失敗して後悔するんですかね
恐ろしいんですよ 成功したら驚くべきなのに
当たったぞと 今日はと
だからそこですよ 明るい答えは
ただ 何かに入れ替えるっていうのは一時的にいいかもしれませんだけど
正しい答えじゃないんです
何かに別なことに入れ替えるより先に
思考には問題あります
そこを直すべきんじゃないかなと思いますね
はい  社員の方で一応ではチェックポイントというのがありますけども
逆転はありますか あの最後の方で
体の調子波はいいか悪いか
あともう一つ 心の波の働きはすごく使いなかったということを聞きますけど
体の方は割と分かりやすいんですけども
心の働きはすごく使い難いというのは
もう少し具体的に教わりたくて
特にあの えーと ややとすると
心の働きが悪いのか それとも怠けているのか
結構分かりにくい 怠けっているのに心の働きが悪いんだとかって自分で理由をつけてあるようなそれがあるんですよ
あの心の調子っていうことも
それほど難しく考えない方がいいんです
難しく考えると確実に間違います
物事は全てすごいシンプルです
ですから 体の調子が悪いんだったらよくわかるでしょうしね
まあ例えば まあ外を見てください
気分はどうでしょうかね
それは心の調子なんですよ
で で 朝も起きたら窓の外から見たら
すぐ自分が何調子かと心がね
すぐわかりますよ だからそんな難しく取ることじゃないんで
例えば今外を見るとなんか窓も曇ってるし
なんか雨が降ってるか降らないか
なんか曖昧で おそらく寒いだろうとかね
なってくると なんか心が活発にならないですね
で そういうことで怠けも入っちゃうと
いや やめちゃっていうことになりますよ
それで活発になりませんだけど
こんなことしちゃうと怠けるんだからね
外へ堂々と出かけてやるぞという風にやることはできます
あの心の波は簡単に変えられますが
体の波はそうちょこちょこと難しいんですね
しかし 心も時々は 1時間ぐらいもう放っておいてくれというね
30 分ぐらい放っておいてくれというふうな時もあります
波がこのちょっと簡単に変わらないという時もあります
怠けじゃないなっていうラインは
怠けは別でやりたくないということだからね
気持ち的には やりたくないことで
やりたいんだけどやれないことですと違いますからね
やりたいんだけど動かない
これも今日は私は昨日作りたいと思っていたんです
しかし ものすごく体が疲れて
大変疲れていて でもどうにもならん
それでまあ 6時 まあ 5時半ぐらい
午後 じゃあもう立ってもいられない
ちょこっと寝てやるぞと思って
もう寝てみたんですけど
まあそれでまあ一応まあ肉体の力が抜けちゃって
色々戻ったんです 戻っても起きて
まあそれからじゃあもう
それで心は回転してくれない
いろいろ工夫したんですけど
まあ心は別や もうその仕事にはもう
入ってこないんですよ
ものすごいスピードで回転してくれないと
私の場合難しいんだからね
まあまあ えーと これ それは自分にはできません
ものすごいスピードで動いてくれないと
で 動いてくれない  それでまあ 12時も過ぎてから
まあちょこちょこっとポイントをね
半分ぐらい押さえておいて
で  2時半か 3時間で まあこれは肉体に悪いんだから寝るぞということで寝て
また朝も紅茶 紅茶でも飲んでから
まあ次はもう自分のスピードでさーっと書いて終わっちゃうんです
ですからね 波っていうのはそういう風にいろいろあるんですよ
だから まあ怠けかどうか自分では考えなかったんですけど
もしかすると怠け出したかもしれませんね
でも怠けで じゃあ頑張るぞと思って
私は仕事をできないと教えてます
昨日作って終わった方がいいんじゃないかと
楽じゃないかと じゃあ昨日とにかく踏ん張るぞと言ってもできないんだから
できないと言ったっても
結果がなかったら意味がないでしょうに
まあ大したことなく なんとかなんとかなんとかっていうのは
まあ自分としてはまああまり好ましくない
皆様には理解 ご理解が完璧にできてもできなくても
一旦世間に向けて発表するものでだから
もうものには欠陥は残さないよというね
発表する内容には だからその点で見れば失敗だから
もうやっぱり朝作っちゃったんです
昨日夜はもうどう...まあいわゆるエラーチェックは臨理であるよということだけ
もうこれはどうやって立証して書くのかと
自分の頭の中で立証できてあるんです
それはすごい専門的で
ものすごい専門的だから
これはもう大変難しいんだから
だから一般的な思考でこれを立証させなくちゃいけない
これでじゃあ今日やるぞということにしたんです
で 今日といったら時間ないんだから
そんな脳には遊べませんね
ふざけたことはできない
時間がないんだから で
回転してくれると そういうわけで
どんな人を見ても生ものだから
心も波があります それはすぐわかりますよ
問題は心が動かなくても
そんなわがまま通じない時はあります
その時サッと機能します
大丈夫です もうそんな怠けてる場合じゃないという場合は
もう本当に心は動きますよ
体もその時は動いてくれます
例えば体の調子が悪くても
そんなことを言ってられる場合じゃないならば
もうちゃんと動きます
それほど大きい問題じゃありません
足の骨が折れた折ったっても
もう山の折れます 下りることできるんだから
そんなことを言ってる場合じゃないんだからね
山でもう 大変なことになっちゃって
もう誰も知らないところで
もう骨も折れてると 雪でもう滑っちゃって
それでも本人には下りることはできます
ですから やっぱり慈しみっていうのは大事なそういうわけなんですよ
この馬鹿力出すのは慈しみが機能している時なんですよ
こんなこと言ってる場合じゃないんだよということは
すごい人間に自分が何かやらなくちゃいかんだからね
その時 慈しみが機能しているんです
だから慈しみこそが奇跡なんです
はい そういうことで  心の調子っていうのはすごい簡単にわかります
それは怠けと本当に区別してください
怠けっていうのは やりたくはないという
面白くはない 心の調子が悪いっていうのは
これやらなくちゃあかんだけどね
今日は締め切りなのに
どうもうまくいかないという調子なんです
どうも頭が回転しないんだと
怠けじゃないんで その場合は
では  では 回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
拝の後に慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれた功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の人々しい生き物に回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての人々しい生き物が幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サンビーティヨ ヴィヴァンジャントゥ サムバローゴ ウィナッサトゥ マテー バワットワンテラーヨ スティディーガー ユコーバヴァ
ババトゥ サッブェ マンガラン ラッカントゥ サムバデーヴァタ サムバブンダヌバーヴェナ サムバダンマ
ヌバーヴェナ サムバサンガーヌバーヴェナ サダー スッティ バワントゥ テ アビワダナシーリッセ ニッチャン ワッダパジャイナ
チャッターロ ダンマ ワッダンティ アユワンノ スカン バラン
はい そういうわけで終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます